the realm
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for a holy [ __ ] what did i just
watch video well the third episode is
now over and I'm still trying to collect
all my thoughts I honestly don't even
know where to begin I will need to watch
that episode again before I make my full
breakdown video I just want to give some
initial thoughts in this video anyways I
guess we will just start at the
beginning of the episode I think they
did do a really good job at building the
tension and suspense as we were waiting
for the army of the Dead to attack there
were thousands and thousands of soldiers
and animals out there on the battlefield
but it was complete silence it gave off
a very creepy vibe then after several
moments of silence guess who decided to
show up and join the fight that's right
Melisandre did arrive in time for the
battle for Winterfell not only did she
show up but it looked like she must have
leveled up in volantis I did love how
Melisandre was able to ignite all of the
Dothraki weapons unfortunately that did
not really matter
they all died moments later I also did
like how you could see all of the fire
from their weapons going out one by one
I actually thought as soon as they died
and it got silent again I was expecting
all of them to get turned into whites
then immediately start charging back at
Winterfell now I do want to say
something else about Melisandre
obviously my niece Aneesa theory did not
come true I thought Melisandre would
sacrifice herself in a much different
way however she was pretty badass during
the episode she was able to do some
things that I was not expecting which I
did like now just in case any of you
were wondering Melisandre did die at the
end of the episode
now that the army the dead are defeated
she can rest so she took off her
necklace and collapsed a few feet later
I will definitely miss Melisandre
because I always thought she was a
fascinating character we also found out
what Melisandre meant when she met Arya
for the first time
and in that darkness eyes staring back
at me brown eyes blue eyes green eyes
eyes you'll shut forever
we will meet again when she told Aria
that she would close blue eyes she was
actually talking about the army of the
Dead and she might have even been
talking about the night King so let's go
ahead and talk about aria start killing
the night king how many of you thought
brain stark knew exactly what he was
doing when he gave aria that dagger last
season I did always say that bran had a
very funny look on his face when he gave
her that dagger now maybe he knew that
Aria would kill Littlefinger by using
the dagger but maybe he also knew that
same dagger would go on to defeat the
night king since bran Stark is still
alive maybe we will find out more later
now when it came to killing the night
king obviously I was not expecting it to
happen exactly like that I have always
felt like John and the night king should
have a sword fight before the series
came to an end when we saw John starting
to run at the night king I thought holy
[ __ ]
here we go we are finally gonna see
these two faced off but the night king
did some sucker [ __ ] and instead of
fighting John when he had the chance he
raised the whites instead I got to be
honest I was very disappointed in the
night king when he did that now I will
say I thought it was badass when Danny
caught the night king on fire one thing
that many of us did think was fire would
not hurt the knight came we have seen
him walk right through it before but
holy [ __ ] I was actually surprised that
he was able to stand there and take
direct dragon fire not only did it not
face him but he even smiled back at Dany
once she was done when I saw him do that
for a moment I thought they might not be
able to kill this son of a [ __ ] I was
actually surprised that Valyrian steel
was enough to get the job done you see
dragon fire is the main ingredient that
makes a Valyrian steel so special
since dragon fire did not affect the
knight king it's crazy that little-ass
blade was enough to kill him and his
entire army we may end up finding out
more about that blade later Samwell
Tarly did see that blade in one of the
books from the Citadel maybe he still
has that book at Winterfell with him if
it did not end up getting caught on fire
during the battle now I will say it was
a little heartbreaking to see the Starks
Castle get destroyed by the night Kings
Dragon this is exactly why we will most
likely see John and Danny back on
Dragonstone later in this season I would
be very surprised if anyone can stay at
Winterfell until some major renovations
are made to the castle now since I'm
talking about Winterfell let's talk
the crypts of Winterfell the crypts were
not exactly the safest location to hide
although they were so much safer than
being outside in the battle now correct
me if I'm wrong but I don't think any
other statues came back to life I did
see some lights coming out of the ground
but those scenes were very dark I wasn't
exactly sure what the hell was happening
those are one of the scenes that I will
need to go back and look at again now
thanks to Arya Stark they never did have
to use any of the secret tunnels to
escape I did think there was a very good
chance that we could see them but I did
also expect the night King to get
defeated at Winterfell if he had been a
subscriber on my channel ever since the
beginning then you and know this is
where I said the night king would die
now he might not have fought Jon Snow in
a sword fight like I wanted but he was
still killed by another member of House
Stark in Winterfell this family has a
very close connection to the night King
and the White Walkers dating all the way
back to the very first long night when
House Stark was founded and the White
Walkers were created
now the television show obviously
doesn't have enough time to go into
every little detail but in the books I
still fully believe we will find out the
Starks and the White Walkers are related
in some way there are just way too many
connections between the Starks and the
White Walkers for them not to be
after all the Starks words our winter is
coming their houses Winterfell
their house sword is called ice their
crypts a wonderful are full of dead
kings of winter which basically
describes exactly what the night king is
or was all of this in my opinion
directly relates to the White Walkers
that's why the Starks Castle was created
directly after the first long night
ended as soon as the White Walkers were
defeated the first time they needed to
make sure they can never make it south
again so that's when Brandon the Builder
made the wall then he made Winterfell
the wall was the first line of defense
against the White Walkers but if they
ever made it through that wall
Winterfell would be the next line of
defense this is why a stark must always
remain in Winterfell
so that if the day should ever come when
the White Walkers invaded again it would
need to be a stark that defeats them in
some way now I know there are many fans
that are upset about the night King
getting defeated so early but I expected
him to lose at Winterfell
the Starks house was always meant to be
the location of the White Walkers deep
this is where winter will fall I have
made several videos on all those
connections before I will make sure to
leave a link in the description if any
of you want to check them out so like I
said earlier I would have definitely
like to see John fight the night king in
a 1 versus 1 sword fight as you all know
this has been John's mission ever since
he found out about the army of the Dead
which was in the very first season of
the show he basically spent his entire
life focusing on defeating them however
if John was not going to be the one to
kill the night king I am still kind of
happy that it was someone from House
Stark I would have been very
disappointed if some random character
like the Hound or Barrack or whoever
else killed the night king for all the
reasons I listed above it had to be
someone from House Stark
this family's history runs too deep with
the White Walkers for it to be anyone
else now let me give my thoughts on some
of the other characters that are dead
how about that Lyanna Mormont seen holy
[ __ ]
now talk about going out in style now it
sucks whenever you have to see a child
die especially in battle like that but
her getting to take out a giant at the
same time was pretty badass then we got
to see her and Lord Commander Delores
said come back as whites
that was crazy I thought we would
actually get a scene of them trying to
attack some of the main characters but I
don't recall ever seeing them attack
anyone after they came back unless I'm
mistaken then of course you have her
cousin Jorah Mormont he showed up in the
clutch for a few moments I thought
Daenerys was definitely about to die not
only did she not have any weapons at the
time but she had White's all around her
that was a scary scene now it did seem
very convenient that George just so
happened to be right there when Danny
was about to get attacked but this is a
massive battle those types of things are
expected now I do want to take some time
to say something about Theon Greyjoy I
think most of us thought he would die in
battle not only did he not have very
many men but he also volunteered for one
of the dangerous jobs available now I
know that some of you hate Theon Greyjoy
but I'm not one of them there was a time
when I did not like the character but he
did grow on me over the years I was
happy that he was able to get some
closure from the Starks he'll even for a
moment it did seem like brains showed
some emotion for Theon I did like what
he said to him I think since Brian knew
he was about to die he could not let
fian die with
thanking him he knew he was ready to
sacrifice himself for the greater good
of the realm say what you want about
Theon but he went out like a soldier he
knew that he had no chance of killing
the night king but he gave it a try
anyway I have to respect that because
that took heart I actually wasn't sure
what happened to ragle until I saw the
trailer for the next episode I was not
able to see where he went during the
fight but he is in the trailer for the
next episode so I know that he did make
it out of the battle Daenerys and John
will certainly need both of the dragons
because they lost a shitload of men now
it should be interesting to see how they
take on Cersei and you're on next
like I said I just wanted to give some
of my initial thoughts on tonight's
episode because I know all of you wanted
me to release a video as soon as I could
I will make a full breakdown video next
as of right now I only saw the episode
one time so I will need to watch it
again to see what all I might have
missed
obviously there are so many more things
that I need to discuss hopefully you all
come back for that next video anyways I
want to thank you all for watching and I
want to thank everyone that supports the
channel I really appreciate that have a
good day I'll see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you